[Musique]
trouve qu'on n'est pas assez tout chez
nous les jeunes par exemple les
élections municipales tout ça il m'a dit
municipal ouais mais c'est pas municipal
c'est départementale est d'accord au
théâtre avait tendu qu'on ne savait pas
du coup sinon j'aurais dis et pas ce
mental aujourd'hui est ce que tu es allé
voter non je ne suis pas allé voter mais
je pense que faire de ben alors demain
ça peut être un peu tard toujours dû
prouver je vais y aller tout à l'heure
quand je redonne bardella a glissé son
bulletin dans l'urne à saint denis c'est
une femme assesseur qui lui a tendu la
feuille d'émargement a signé mais un
détail a son importance cette femme
assesseur était voilée à l'image on voit
donc le numéro deux du rassemblement
national qui veut interdire le voile
dans l'espace public est une femme
voilée qui lui tend la feuille
d'émargement
l'image n'est pas anodine elle
interpelle d'ailleurs jordan bardella
s'est empressé de la poster sur twitter
c'est vrai parce qu'en fait en addition
on fait des débats à longueur de journée
sur les frontières sur l'immigration
l'insécurité que c'est ce que les gens
mangent à la fin du mois ce que les gens
mangent à la fin du mois c'est un
salaire un travail le frigo qui se
remplit le quotidien et les transports
les choses comme ça et bien sûr ils sont
intéressés par ces questions là parce
que des fois ça dérange leur vie mais
années quand même le quotidien de se
casser la tête tous les matins et de
savoir qu'est-ce que je bouffe à la fin
du mois ça ne mange pas des petits
musulmans dans au dîner
prochaine étape une mélange de vos
fruits rouges avec un mixeur plongeant
pour obtenir une texture onctueuse
ça me fait penser
il me faire opérer 7 j'ai essayé de
faire un geste opératoire qui était
censé ne pas apporter de la beauté mais
au contraire du la monstruosité de
l'horreur et effectivement je me suis
fait placer des implants qu'on met
habituellement sur les pommettes sur les
tempes et si on me décrit comme une
femme qui à deux bosses sur les tempes
on peux me considérer comme un monstre
absolument être désirable en termes de
chirurgie donc j'ai refait messin trois
fois mon âge et mes fesses deux fois et
pour l'élève passe à tous les 6 mois
voilà le botox et moi c'est une histoire
d'amour bon je pense que vous l'avez
remarqué à la vache à pâte elle robocup
de la chirurgie esthétique en ont en
fait tu leur beau coq tu peux
dégradables et ma chérie citant le
compte en banque et la carte bleue pour
te faire plaisir c'est le je pense que
cit aurait les moyens
tu leur ai fait ma chérie surtout que
kara à côté de vous qui êtes en train de
monter sa petite boîte à c'est une start
up pour ceux qui sont sur m6 avec nous
je dis parce que certaines ne le voit
pas elle récupère des vieux matelas ont
fait dérober chemisier ça vous fait quoi
d'être en face de moi là bas c'est
énorme je suis complètement bouleversée
moi j'en ai marre vraiment je vendrais
tendances high et j'en peux plus j'en
peux plus on me trouve personne
j'ai trop parfaite c'est l'histoire de
victoria et alexander deux jeunes
ukrainiens qui le 14 février dernier
jour de la saint valentin on fait un
constat leur couple battait de l aile
alors pour redonner de l'élan à leur vie
amoureuse ils ont décidé de se moquer
l'un à l'autre attachée par le poignet
24 heures sur 24
ça sent la mauvaise idée mourir et vous
eh bien vous avez raison puisque au bout
de 124 jours ils ont fini par se séparer
au sens propre comme au figuré
je me la mets revêt pour eux c'est faire
du contentieux
nous partageons serré
124 jours à aller aux toilettes ensemble
cuisiner ensemble assister aux
conversations téléphoniques de l'autre
patienter pendant la séance maquillage
plus aucune once de mystère l'un pour
l'autre
seul intérêt de ce calvaire bas ils
peuvent désormais se targuer de détenir
le record du monde du couple ayant passé
le plus de temps menotté l'un à l'autre
libéré
il compte mettre leur paire de menottes
aux enchères donc oui des menottes ça
peut servir pour pimenter une vie
amoureuse mais pas en s'attachant à l'un
à l'autre c'est la leçon de cette
histoire
quel est l'endroit la maison où l'on
préfère faire l'amour c'est la question
qui se pose est un site de vente en
ligne britannique avec une méthodologie
étonnante
les chercheurs ont mesuré la fréquence
cardiaque de cinquante couples avant et
juste après le rapport sexuel à
différents endroits
les résultats ont ensuite été compilée
avec la note qualitative que ces cobayes
ont attribué à chacun de leurs rapports
sexuels
l'objectif final étant bien sûr de
trouver la pièce la plus excitant oui
mais où vit à londres
[Musique]
notre appli et ce qui est sûr c'est que
c'est pas la chambre à coucher
figurez-vous nom qui récolte le plus de
battement pas de coeur par minute les
faits de l'habitude peut-être en tout
cas la chambre fini la sixième place du
classement juste avant l'escalier et oui
les marches pour rejoindre les solos
mais c'est pas évident ça fait mal a
regretté que la douleur et l'inconfort
de l'endroit permettez-moi facilement je
cite d'atteindre l'orgasme
que signifient les pektas suis je donc
unités les pektas études thèse je donne
ma langue au chat
et bien c'est le fait de mourir pendant
un acte sexuel au moment de l'orgasme
alors c'est un fait et connaissez pas la
définition de ces mots la salle de bains
qui elles récoltent tous les suffrages
de l'état les cobayes ont apprécié les
vapeurs d'eau chaude et le film on va
refaire l'amour de pouce vous avez l'air
bien au courant mais la fréquence
cardiaque découpe avoisinerait même les
120 battements par minute ce qui est le
voilà à peu près l'équivalent d'un
morceau de techno il y en a qui savent
vivre
les discothèques vont pouvoir ouvrir
leurs portes le 9 juillet les
professionnels du monde de la nuit
attendaient cette décision depuis plus
d'un an déjà
et oui ces établissements où les gestes
barrières sont difficiles à appliquer
rouvriront avec des jauges limitées et
présentation du pass sanitaires en
revanche le masque ne sera pas
obligatoire sur la piste de danse et ça
y est la fête recommence des amis
[Musique]
m
qui a créé la fête de la musique est ce
un jack lang ou deux jack ocak oeil ah
oui jack lang j'accueille d'accord
après avoir perdu son bras dans un
accident de la circulation
cette passionnée de violon a pu
reprendre son instrument grâce à cette
prothèse qui a été conçu pour elle une
belle façon de rappeler que vivre avec
un handicap n'empêche pas de réaliser
des prouesses si on va l'écouter
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
oui
et puis pour le reste on se retrouve
très bientôt au pays sur vous et puis on
vous embrasse les amis ça l'est